[Music]
in the world of anime there are these
amazing times when all the heroes team
up to fight a big bad villain these epic
battles become legendary in anime
because they show how powerful teamwork
can be so we've done our research and
narrowed down a list to show the top
moments when everyone teamed up to fight
the villain in anime we start with
jiu-jitsu Sorcerers versus
Kaku right after we'd finally gotten to
see mahito get his butt kicked Kaku
entered the picture and the Kyoto
jiujitsu Sorcerers came along to fight
against him along with choso panda and
Yuji you'd think that these Sorcerers in
a death painting womb would be enough to
face off against gjaku but you'd be
mistaken gjaku was an absolute beast and
he could have handled everyone even
without Ur Ami's help he showed how he
easily beat everyone up pretty casually
and neglected all of their attacks even
miwa using a binding vow was of no use
in the fight and just showed how strong
genju is if Aizen is disrespectful genju
literally rejected mea from having a
moment of redemption overall the fight
was awesome and seeing a new St of
Uzumaki was just eye candy I just
imagine how good it would have been if
utar
appeared
[Music]
next up on the list we have Oaken
against everyone from ranking of
[Music]
Kings now Oken is an exceptionally
powerful villain being a former
commander of the order of the underworld
to defeat this terrifying foe the the
big four Master combatants had to face
him off at the same time right after Boi
had his battle with him these Masters
were exceptionally powerful but 's
Immortal body allowed him to take all of
their blows and regenerate back like
nothing even happened it wasn't until
the reincarnated boss joined the fight
that we saw Oaken taste defeat well he
was literally crushed and stuffed into a
rock but watching this fight scene and
seeing the heroes join together and win
at the end was just so
satisfying
[Music]
next we have the Z Fighters teaming up
to fight Cell from Dragon Ball
[Music]
Z circle before the tournament of power
we had the Cell Games and before that we
were shown how big of a threat this guy
truly is even during sell's initial form
he was a force to be reckoned with and
the Androids had to team up with the Z
fighters to have a Fighting Chance
Piccolo TN Android 16 Android 17 and
Android Android 18 took part in this
battle and they effectively got their
butts handed to them in the beginning
everyone had put up a pretty good fight
but once cell absorbed Android 17 the
tables turned completely on our heroes
the dude was a devastating villain
overall and ultimately flexed his
strength in the entirety of this fight
although admittedly s didn't look too
terrifying for a Villain at first since
he looked so much like a bug the power
he displayed fighting against everyone
certainly bumped him up the list coupled
with the power up from Android 17 cell
became the biggest threat at that time
[Music]
[Applause]
slipping into the list we have utsuro as
he takes on literally everyone in
Gintama utsuro arrives and his Naraku
completely obliterates anyone that
stands in their way gintoki's allies
were in big trouble but luckily more and
more of them arrived to drive the Naraku
and utsuro back from the shinsen goui to
the yato tribes to Ninjas the fighting
was pure brutality with utsuro just
massacring gintoki's allies it was a
battle of epic proportions and true to
his name as one of gintama's ultimate
villains utsuro was dealing too much
damage even if he was wounded also uturo
is Immortal too just like Oken so you
can see a pattern here where Immortal
villains normally have multiple heroes
or more specifically in this case two
armies facing off against them to stand
a chance everyone was giving their all
just to defeat this one guy and you'd
literally get goosebumps watching
[Music]
it everyone facing off against Goliath
from is it wrong to try and pick up
girls in a
[Music]
dungeon Goliath wasn't a particular
particularly smart villain but its power
and defense were off the charts it was
literally like a raid boss in any RPG
game you'd play Bell's group and the
Expedition group had to work together to
take it down our heroes got bashed
around for the better part of the fight
even though everyone was combining their
strengths the gath's Monstrous figure
made it seem like the heroes could face
The end at any point and this made the
stakes even higher the number of cold
attacks from Gravity sword to fire Moon
looked absolutely stunning making Dan
Machi one of the better animated isekai
the fight was aome from start to finish
the tension the buildup and then the
final clashes were all gorgeously
executed and was one of the fights that
propelled Bell's
reputation next we have the seven deadly
sins against the demon
king even those who haven't seen the
anime must know the high mistakes of the
fight since the villain is literally
named The Demon King we all know how
strong demon Kings normally are
considering their namesake and this one
was amongst the strongest in all of
anime we already saw a giant monster in
the last entry but the Demon King here
was as large as an entire country our
heroes are nothing to scoff at but the
Demon King's power completely dwarfed
them that's what made the entire fight
so awesome as we got to see all of the
sins fight up max power and showcase
their most awesome abilities melodus
then fully countered the massive spell
everyone launched multiple times to
finally devastate The Demon King which
to me was a 10,000 IQ move it was a
perfect boss fight that marked the first
steps towards the end of their
Journey now we're switching from
monstrous villains to humanized villains
for this entry we have alter versus
everyone from
[Music]
recreators
I say that they're human size but that
doesn't mean that they aren't powerful
alter was in all regards the ultimate
creation of setsuna shimazaki and her
plan was to have Worlds Collide to bring
about massive destruction and destroy
all creation from both the real world
and the story worlds she also had the
strength and intelligence to back it up
and so all our heroes had to band
together to even have the chance of
stopping her they couldn't initially do
much though as we can literally see Al
casually beating up the heroes one after
the other without even batting an ey it
wasn't until Sirus showed up that alter
had to put in a little bit more effort
overall this fight was gorgeously
animated not to mention how the
soundtrack was an absolute Banger the
team up led to a stunning battle that
had you on your toes for the entirety of
it slamming his way on this list is a
corrupted Golem against everyone from
Princess
[Music]
connect yes
this battle is much like the one with
Goliath where a bunch of our adventurers
take down a huge monster oh and there
are cute girls in this fight so that's
always a plus isn't it the stakes aren't
too high but that doesn't mean the
battle itself isn't spectacular the
animation may possibly be the best
amongst the entries on this list until
now and even more colorful than the
battle in recreators seeing as how the
Golem had a whole Army of minions we
can't even call the odds unfair for the
villain it wasn't an easy fight as well
as at one point you'd think the heroes
had exhausted themselves but then Karine
comes to the rescue with one more power
up and finally decimates the weakened
Golem with an attack that finally made
me breathe again you might think that
there were no action scenes in an anime
named princess connect but that's where
you're
[Music]
wrong destroying his way into this list
we have shigaraki versus Our Heroes from
my hero
Academia
going
fans watching the series already know
that shigaraki is being developed as an
astounding antagonist but at this point
in the anime he'd gotone to a completely
different level shigaraki literally made
a large number of pro Heroes run from
his power as he almost disintegrated an
entire city to fight the villain bakugo
deu eraser head Hawks Endeavor Gran
Torino and ryuko had to team up it just
goes to show how much of a threat
shigaraki was even with a razorhead
neutralizing shigaraki's quirks he still
proved to be too much of a threat to
everyone around him near the end
shigaraki had effectively injured and
taken out most of the heroes before all
for one showed up to wipe out everyone
it sure is one heck of a fight that
leave you falling from your seat since
the heroes were clearly not the
strongest around and it's also one of
the few moments where the villains
actually win but we won't be stopping
here since next on the list we have Kito
and the Gang versus the H 100th floor
boss from Sword Art
[Music]
Online
you know the heroes are in for a tough
fight when epic boss music starts
playing also I must say that the boss
sure has one of the coolest designs on
this list it's literally a huge Angelic
and demonic being with multiple huge
swords and some overpowered longrange
lasers not to say that our heroes were
any less since they displayed some super
flashy moves the battle involves epic
choreography as you see the characters
work together while fighting this
overpowered boss and this is a testament
to the animators since they gorgeously
animated all of it even with all of the
chaos and dazzling lights it wasn't too
difficult following the combat and the
entire moment topped here I mean there
was quite literally magic swords and
guns the team even gave fans a sweet hit
of nostalgia by having Kito and Aruna
transform into their old clothes and
designs as well as the appearances of
characters from the different seasons of
Sao you'll get literal
[Music]
[Applause]
Goosebumps moving on this list is
another monstrous being known as the
medium against every nation from the
anime
[Music]
Magi it's a being full of Fury that
shows no emotion and simply intends to
destroy the world it's a lot like the
t-tailed beast from Naruto and just as
powerful too to defeat a beast that can
possibly bring the destruction of the
entire world a significantly large team
is required in this case some of the
strongest magicians from every nation
showed up to fight it and they didn't
disappoint the best part was that we got
to see EX magic after it was launched by
our heroes and it looked pretty sweet
even with all the magic being cast the
medium was still barely vulnerable until
Aladdin noticed the hesitance in the
Beast and went to talk with Mamet the
scale of this battle was just something
else because it's kind of rare that
these people fight
[Music]
together before end entering the top 10
of this list we have all the Fate
servants versus the demon god king
[Music]
gatia seems like team ups against demon
Kings and gods are the way to go because
it always seems to take more than one
hero to fight off such cataclysmic
villains if you thought SEO had some
cool cameos then wait until you see this
one because almost every single
character is here the amazing moves they
pull off while battling gatier to save
mankind keep you on the edge of your
seat the fight scene also had some sweet
background music to back all the amazing
visuals that you see and The Clash of
ideals makes everything all the better
from Gilgamesh to Rama to quoto to
Mozart they were ready to throw hands
their entrance was so cold too and I
wish we could get another battle in fate
as big as this
one before we reveal the top 10 how
about giving this video a like and
subscribing to the channel if you
haven't done so already thank you
entering the top 10 of this list we have
melard against the S-Class heroes in one
punch
man melard classified as a dragon level
threat possessed immense power he
demonstrated his strength by swiftly
defeating Sky King a monster comparable
in level to the Deep Sea King with just
one blow so it's no wonder that it
required four S-Class Heroes to beat the
monster and even then it took quite a
bit of work on their end considering
melag guard's regeneration abilities
well technically only ion was the only
one who got beat up by melard as the
S-Class Heroes took little to no damage
during the entirety of the fight did I
mention how good the animation during
this team up was you can literally watch
the fight at a quarter of the speed and
see all of atomic Samurai's movements
while cutting up the villain it was a
rare chance to get to see the S-Class
fighting together and boy was it worth
it
next up we have everyone versus Victor
from Undead
unluck and once again regeneration is a
big factor here fans of the series
already know how strong Andy is with his
regeneration abilities but who' have
thought that he'd be hosting a villain
like Victor inside himself much like
itadori host sukuna well everyone got a
taste to Victor when he appeared and
they all had to work together to have a
Fighting Chance Victor and Andy's
regeneration multiplied by 100 which is
crazy seeing as Andy's regeneration was
already crazy to begin with Andy has to
change to Victor to defeat spoil but
then all members of the Round Table
after to show up just to force Victor to
convert back to Andy it's also very
clear that Victor wasn't even going full
force against everyone since things
would have ended much differently if
that happened all that aside getting to
see all the round table members go all
out against the guy who can't die it was
a pretty cool battle to watch and we
probably won't get to see such a team up
again in the anime anytime soon or will
we who
knows flying its way into this list we
have former claw members against
shimazaki from Mob psycho
[Music]
100 shimasaki really showed off his
strength during this fight and even with
a particularly powerful team up of
Heroes and ex villains he still thrashed
them fairly heavily the fight had some
high stakes in the fact that the heroes
were technically fighting someone like
Gojo saturo I say that Loosely not to
annoy fans of the series but shimazaki
was pretty op which is why he had so
many guys going after him simultaneously
the fight was pretty awesome and over
the top considering mob psycho's Godly
animation style and boy was it
satisfying to see so much destruction
wouldn't have minded seeing mob in
action too but hey I'm still happy with
the team up I got
[Music]
next we have an entry from one of the
big three of Shonen eizen versus the
goate 13 and the
visards eyes and from Bleach was
originally a captain in the goate 13 but
then was revealed to be a villain who
was one of the smartest characters in
the series so this fight was long in the
making when eizen finally faced off
against the captains of Soul Society
along with a few former captains and
visards the team up involved literally
the strongest members of Soul Society
but they still couldn't hold a candle to
The Mastermind Isen as he fought all of
them together and brought them to their
knees through his power abilities and
just Raw Battle IQ the fight marked a
major turning point in the plot and
helped the series showcas case aizen's
power it was pretty cool watching so
many captains go up against Aizen and
just be completely destroyed what he did
to hit sugayan by making him kill one of
his own subordinates was just too
disrespectful too bad the team up
resulted in a loss though just goes to
show how strong Isen truly was and how
plot armor was the only thing that could
defeat
[Music]
him coming in next we have another
recent team up where the scouts and
warriors fought against Erin from Attack
on
Titan during the middle of the series no
one could have expected that the scouts
and warriors two factions opposing each
other would team up to fight an even
bigger threat and who would have thought
that the threat would end up being the
series original protagonist no wonder
Attack on Titan is a masterpiece that
assigned to defeat Aaron and his army of
colossal Titans all the remaining Scouts
including Levi and masasa had to work
work with the Warriors such as Rina and
his gang the fight was epic in every way
possible with top tier animation this
would be the last time we'd see Titans
fight against each other and the last
time we see everyone go all out Rhino
was killing it and we saw what would
happen if the Armored Titan started
becoming aggressive not only that
previous users of their Titans also
joined in and it was one hell of an
ending for a legendary
series before we enter the top three of
this list we have AA yuno Yami and the
others against the devil from Black
Clover we're not done with demons just
yet but this is going to be the last
entry with such a being coming up as the
villain the first devil was such a
strong opponent that it seemed like
absolutely no one could ever beat him
even if everyone would all work together
the devil casually overpowered some of
the strongest characters in the series
which made things more intense the best
moment was probably when Yami showed up
to give master and you know a hand the
dimension SL yamy launched at the Devil
accompanied by some awesome music
surprised literally everyone including
the devil itself ASA then surpassed his
own limits to land the final blow
closing off an epic team up of course
the animation was top-n too and so were
all the flashy moves so no wonder the
team secured such a rank on this list
and come on you got to admit the devil
plot twist was
[Music]
good
coming in at number three we have
everyone facing off against father from
Full Metal
Alchemist the final battle against
father involves a group effort from
various characters as they fight in
Central Command father harnesses
incredible alchemical powers and
attempts to ascend into a higher form of
existence so Edward Mustang scar
Armstrong and others team up to take him
down they use all their special skills
to weaken father Mustang's Firepower
Edward's Alchemy knowledge and Armstrong
strength helped chip away at father's
defenses along with the rest of the army
but not before father showed how truly
terrifying he really was in the end
their teamwork does pay off the fight is
amazing in every aspect from the
cornography to the sounds to the visuals
the buildup was perfect and so was the
climax of the fight team ups barely get
better than this
one coming in at number two we have a
fight from one piece when the scabbards
face off against
kaido technically speaking kaido had the
largest number of Heroes going after him
during the entire Arc but this specific
team up was when the scabbards United to
fight against him the scabbards had the
longest history with kaido as he took
their Homeland from them and it was
poetic justice for them to face him they
were driven by their deep resolve for
revenge and Justice faced off against
the seemingly Invincible kaido who
possessed immense power as a yonko
despite their incredible teamwork and
unwavering determination the scabbards
were outmatched by kaido's overwhelming
strength they valiantly fought against
him Landing impressive blows and
displaying incredible resilience but it
was just too much in the end the
scabbards even mimicked Odin's attacks
but unlike Odin they never made kaido
feel pain the fight was still a gorgeous
sight to behold considering the killer
animation in the music even if the
scabbards Lost kaido still had stronger
people coming for
him and at the top of our list we have
the team up against Madar by the Shinobi
Alliance in
[Music]
Naruto this fight marked the p IAL of
the fourth ninja war as ninja from all
Villages put aside their differences and
banded together unfortunately though the
person who ended up against them was a
resurrected madra uch the person only
second to the god of Shinobi the
alliances coordination and synchronized
attacks were remarkable each ninja
showcased their unique abilities and
skills launching a Relentless assault on
Madara but it's Madara we're talking
about here and he just straight up
started a massacre marar proved to be
too big of an obstacle for everyone to
climb and the moment he got into the
wall was Mark as one of the most amazing
entries any villain had ever made in the
history of anime the largest team up was
required to combat the second strongest
ninja and everything was masterfully
done from the choreography to the
intensity of the fight its Nostalgia and
awesomeness all in
[Music]
one and with that we're wrapping up this
list of the top 21 moments when everyone
teamed up to fight the villain in anime
there were numerous moments in anime
where the heroes team up to fight so we
must have missed out some of your
favorites don't keep us hanging though
be sure to comment down below any team
ups you think should have made it to
this list and if you enjoyed this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe so we
can make more this juicy content see you
next time